after 20 years of practicing engineering
in many organizations i felt the need to
upskill
i had to manage and evaluate the
relationship with partners and you
cannot do that without good data
and i wouldn't be able to
achieve that without the skills that i
got from
the simple learn data science courses so
i'm very happy about that my name is
jorge guzman i'm an electronic engineer
a specialist in wireless communication
living in colombia with my family and
upskilling my career for simple learning
when i was a child i liked to collect
toys i had a box full of them and i
enjoyed categorizing them another thing
that i enjoyed about toys was that i was
sometimes able to pull them apart and
put them back together not always but
most of the time so
when the time came to
select a career for my life engineer
makes sense for me that was the time
when i came across simple learn
comprehensive curriculum and data
science and i was sold i wanted to try
it
i have taken many courses from simple
learn in data science including data
science with art that science with
python machine learning for data science
top law
and several others the latest course
that i do was big data last year and it
was amazing so what i did is i applied
my
skills and build cohesive stories based
on data to
evaluate and build better relationships
with those partners data tells the
stories i managed to tell the stories
about my partners that were very
fulfilling for the organization
the customer and myself
currently i'm working in a colombian
fintech
and the skills that i got from my
courses in data science still apply
today because i still involved with
partners and data analysis and
information about those partners still
making a big difference in my role today